let's talk about hypertension and I'll
write that here hypertension and
hypertension basically means high blood
pressure and we actually categorize it
in different groups so let's use my
blood pressure of 115 over 75 as an
example and I had drawn a small figure
for you we're at blood pressure on this
side and I had time on this side and I
said that my blood pressure does
something like that where the peak is
115 this is the systolic blood pressure
and I said that the lowest point is
gonna be for me 75 and that was my
diastolic blood pressure and we know
everyone has a different blood pressure
so let's organize blood pressures into
groups let's say let's figure out kind
of what group goes where and so to do
that I'm gonna draw a couple number
lines so let's imagine that I have here
in brown I'll do my systolic blood
pressure on this side and I'll do the
diastolic on the other side I'll do
diastolic over here and we're gonna
actually put them next to each other and
let's see I'll try to make them at the
same size like that so let's say this is
really high pressure this would be like
200 and this is all in millimeters of
mercury 200 millimeters of mercury and
at the very bottom would be zero so
let's make them kind of the same and
that means that up here would be about a
hundred and this would be about one
let's say this is 120 this is about 140
let's say maybe this is 160 this is 180
and I'm gonna do the same thing here
let's say this is about 100 except this
time you're gonna go on the other side
let's say this is about 80 and 60 40 20
maybe I didn't draw it as as well but I
think you got the idea so so this is my
number line and the reason I drew this
like numbers higher than the diastolic
siz because we know that generally
speaking or not generally speaking
always the systolic pressure is going to
be higher than the diastolic pressure so
that's why I separated it out but you
can imagine that these numbers go up and
these go down and just being lazy not
throwing it all out so let's say that my
pressure is 115 this is my systolic
pressure now let's do that one first
where does that fit well on this number
line one fifteen would be about right
here and actually anything below 120 is
actually kind of in the Green Zone and
this goes all the way down all the way
down to zero so let's say my systolic
was you know 97 or 103 that would all be
in the Green Zone and what I mean by
that is I would say I do not have
hypertension
I have no hypertension so that's kind of
a nice safe area to have your blood
pressure in terms of hypertension now
for diastolic pressures we know that
diastolic pressures are the low range of
a blood pressure and so those numbers
are going to be lower here anything
below 80 is considered kind of in that
safe green zone so below 80 is where you
want to be and and I want to be very
specific I I don't mean to say that a
blood pressure of five would be good
what I mean is that you don't have
hypertension so you don't have high
blood pressure and that's and that's
very different from having low blood
pressure so just for right now the Green
Zone in terms of high blood pressure now
let's say my systolic blood pressure was
a little bit higher let's say it's uh I
don't know let's say it's between 120
and 140 somewhere in here then I'm in
the yellow zone and that yellow zone
means that I don't have hypertension but
I'm getting there right so I'm getting
closer and this would be pre
hypertension and on the other side on
the diastolic side we use 90 as a
cut-off so I'll write in 90 and anything
between 80 and 90 would be kind of in
that yellow zone and that's your pre
hypertension zone that's pre
hypertension so you're still not there
yet
now in terms of high blood pressures
again you don't want high blood
pressures but in terms of getting there
if you're above 140
you have hypertension so this Zone in
here 140 to 160 in particular is
concerned stage 1 hypertension stage 1
and between 90 and 100 for diastolic
that would be stage 1 stage 1 and now if
you have something above 160 for your
systolic blood pressure
so I'll just say above 160 and that
means even higher than 200 so let's say
you have 201 that would be stage 2 so
you can see that the higher you go the
higher your stage number and the same is
true on this side so let's say you have
a really high diastolic blood pressure
well above 100
you'd have stage 2 hypertension all the
way down there this is stage 2 so I'm
just gonna do a couple quick examples
for you so let's say I'll do them in
yellow a different color let's say that
you have 145 as a systolic and your
diastolic is let's say 87 145 is right
here right and 87 is gonna be doing the
same color just to be consistent so 145
is right here and 87 is in here so your
systolic pressure is stage 1
hypertension in your diastolic pressure
is in pre hypertension so when you're in
different stages for the diastolic and
systolic what you do the rule is that
you go with the higher stage then this
stage stage one is higher so this person
would be considered stage 1 hypertension
now we can do one more example just to
make sure you get it so let's do a
different color let's say I'll do the
next one in red so you have let's say
126 over let's say 101 well this person
126 is actually right here
and 101 is right above the hundred mark
right there so this person is actually
pre-hypertensive if you're looking at
just their systolic value but they're
actually in stage 2 hypertension if
you're looking at their diastolic value
so overall they're gonna be in stage 2
because the rule again is that you go at
the higher stage so that's how you
figure out what stage of hypertension
someone's in